Russell's Back was pressed against the
wall his shuddering hands gripping the
fire ax the low emergency lighting
filling the corridor indicated the
lockdown was still in effect although
that was simultaneously a blessing and a
curse sure it meant that thing couldn't
get out hopefully but it also meant that
Russell was stuck in the wing of the
facility with it he had no idea if
anyone else was left he hadn't seen what
had happened to Carpenter maybe it got
him or perhaps he had managed to give it
the slip at the last second there was no
way of knowing for sure it had all
started so simply so innocently and with
such Noble intentions if he had known it
would lead to all this madness Russell
would have never put his name down on
the request form the SCP Foundation had
been working on a way to neutralize or
cure scp-610 for what felt like forever
to one team of scientists the infamously
so-called flesh that hates was a
fascinating organism it was a highly
contagious sarcic skin disease isolated
entirely within the small area of
Siberia that on its own wasn't enough to
Peak the interest of the research team
led by Dr Carpenter including his
hand-picked star researchers Russell and
David along with their assistant clennan
and Dr bottin an expert on infectious
diseases who had recently joined their
efforts to provide his specialist
knowledge what did Captivate all of them
however was what scp-610 did when it
infected a human being the disease would
trigger aggressive and uncontrollable
mutations within its infected and could
virtually rewrite their entire
physiology in a heartbeat the flesh that
hates was capable of transforming a
person's body into a horrifying fleshing
mass of Limbs and matter that barely
resemble the human being anymore and in
addition the infected individuals would
retain some level of awareness attacking
any uninfected person with extreme
hostility there had long been chatter
amongst some other research teams
studying scp-610 about devising a way to
weaponize the disease if they could
somehow create a variant that didn't
turn people into monsters or at least
caused the fleshy Abominations to die
shortly after mutation then the
foundation or another interested party
could deploy the flesh that hates as a
biological weapon Dr Carpenter had long
abhorred the idea instead searching for
a way to completely reverse the effects
of an scp-610 infection it may have been
idealistic perhaps even naive by some
standards but the rest of his team was
behind him in the pursuit of that Noble
goal although not one of them knew it
would soon cost them their lives hitting
speed bump after speed bump in their
research the team were beginning to lose
hope researcher David was the most
outspoken in how tired he was of seeing
the same results yelling in frustration
that the flesh could not be cured by
conventional means however it was that
Outburst that gave Russell the idea they
had tried trading scp-610 like a common
virus as if it was any other form of
disease largely thanks to Dr button's
input and granted that approach had
taught them a lot about the flesh's
ability to contaminate a subject from a
single cell but this infection was
anomalous through and through could the
solution to eradicating it for good lie
not in a medical cure but in another SCP
Russell brought this hypothesis to the
rest of the research team and each of
them had suggestions for other anomalies
they could potentially use to cure a
subject of the flesh that hates we could
get scp-049 to take a look at the
infected patient clenin suggested oh
might work carpents are mused although
even if he cares someone he might also
kill them he has his whole deal about
ridding the world of the pestilence
could prove to be a problem there's
always 682 David said dryly have the
reptile eat up all the scp-610 infectis
and voila problem solved oh real helpful
David researcher Russell retorted and
what are we gonna do when scp-682 adapts
to the flesh you really want an infected
Immortal lizard on the loose Gentlemen
please Dr Button spoke up we're
forgetting one obvious option I propose
we submit a joint formal request to use
scp-914 for this experiment unanimously
the group all agreed that this was the
best course of action
scp-914 or the Clockworks was a giant
machine with two booths marked input and
output although the foundation still
couldn't fully comprehend exactly how as
cp914 seemed to take any object placed
within it and disassemble recreate
improve or destroy the item depending on
its current setting there was one issue
however a prior failed experiment where
in a d-class was placed in scp-914 had
led to some pretty disastrous
consequences as a result ever since no
organic matter was to be placed within
the Clockworks rule that the teams
experiment with the flesh would breach
still they pressed on each of the five
researchers signing their request to
utilize scp-914 before it was submitted
to the foundation higher-ups within
hours the request was denied but the
team was determined that scp-914 could
be the key to solving the foundation's
long-standing issue with scp-610 Dr
Carpenter repealed the decision
urging the higher-ups to reconsider he
argued that this flouting of the no
organic matter rule was necessary to
potentially rid the world of the flesh
that hates after a few days of
consideration the request was finally
Faithfully granted the team went to work
immediately requisitioning two test
subjects both of which had suffered
scp-610 infections and were horribly
mutated the pair of them were deemed a
potential Hazard to every member of
foundation staff on site and as a result
the entire wing of the facility where
the clock works with house had to be
evacuated for safety dressed in
biohazard suits to protect themselves
the researchers used an electric cattle
prod to coax the first flesh specimen
into the input chamber of scp-914 this
was the test run they wanted to see if
the Clockworks would actually be able to
affect those infected with scp-610 at
all plus they needed a Fail-Safe just in
case something went wrong and luckily
the machine had just the thing Russell
asked Clement to set the Clockworks too
rough and with a click in War of its
numerous gears and Gyros
scp-914 came to life instantly the
infected test subject was completely
obliterated the setting had reduced it
to atoms disintegrating it on such a
microscopic level that there was nothing
left in the output chamber the second
infected creature seemed to bristle with
anger but didn't attack or become
aggressive as it too was plotted towards
the Clockworks next perhaps out of fear
that their Theory might be wrong the
team agreed to set scp-914 to its
one-to-one setting sure enough the
machine recreated another instance of a
specimen infected with the flesh that
hates replacing the previous one we all
know we're stalling researcher David
piped up let's do what we came here for
set the Clockworks to coarse nervously
receding a nod from Dr Carpenter Lennon
stepped forward to switch the dial on
scp-914 to the course setting this was
the primary reason the team had all
agreed to use the machine on a flesh
specimen this setting could disassemble
any item placed in the input Booth
separating it into its base components
botton had suggested the use of scp-914
based on the theory that if it worked
correctly the Clockworks could extract
the flesh that hates from its infected
host rendering them free of the disease
the machine made a colossal amount of
noise as clennan hurried back to a safe
distance with the others but as it was
powering up seconds from activating Dr
Carpenter noticed something the color
drained from his face as he saw it none
of the others had noticed from a
distance that the style hadn't been set
to course instead it pointed to very
fine the highest refinement setting 914
had what the hell have you done
Carpenter yelled at clennan before the
machine suddenly activated would step
free from the output Booth stunned the
researcher it was a man a seemingly
ordinary human who had presumably been
infected by scp-610 some time ago he
stepped nervously out of the machine
looking confused for a moment as a para
Foundation security guards cautiously
approached him we did it Russell said in
awe suddenly fleshy tendrils burst forth
from the man's arms latching on to the
approaching guards they screamed in
agony their bodies melting become a
bloody misshapen mass that stayed
attached to the humanoid creature at the
center it was like they became a part of
it the guards arms and legs forming
additional limbs as their forms were
reconstituted and repurposed as part of
a monster that was now crawling on its
six legs towards the research team in a
blind the group scrambled for the
entrance the head of the infected man
splitting open down the middle opening
up into a wide snapping pair of Jaws
panting hard as he ran his breath
fogging up the clear faceplate of The
Biohazard suit Russell ran through the
door hearing someone close behind he
stopped for a moment looking back to see
the creature on the other side of the
door starting to spill through the door
frame like a liquid running faster
around a corner Russell came to another
halt in the common area a third security
guard following just before a thick
Steel security door came slamming down
sealing the creature on the other side
the other door didn't hold it what good
is that going to do researcher David
yelled more to the point Dr Carpenter
said turning and marching towards
Clinton he launched a furious punch at
the assistant knocking him to the floor
why did you set 914 to very fine clennan
the enraged doctor shouted you're the
one who Unleashed that Abomination you
maniac what Clinton replied fearfully
trembling I I didn't I swear I didn't it
said course I'm sure of it you expect us
to believe that was a mistake gentlemen
we need to focus on the situation at
hand the security officer interjected
regardless of who's responsible we need
to inform the foundation higher-ups
there's an emergency lockdown Russell
replied it would have triggered the
moment the scp-610 specimen got free
you've trapped us with a monster clenin
Dr Carpenter spat hold on researcher
David spoke up wasn't it botton's idea
to use 914 in the first place the common
area felt silent as everyone turned to
look at Dr botton did you plan for this
doc David pushed Von chuckled need I
remind you my friends that we all agreed
to use the Clockworks did we not all of
our names are on the request he answered
besides accusing me David that's rather
Rich coming from you what's that
supposed to mean the researcher fired
back beckoning his finger botton
encouraged the rest of the team to
follow him across the common area to
where a row of lockers stood each door
bearing one of their names he gestured
to the one labeled David go on button
added shooting him a dirty look David
barch passed the disease expert and
opened his locker not one among the
group expected what would fall out it
was an old leather-bound book symbols
carved into the front cover instantly
thanks to the work studying scp-610 the
researchers all knew a text on sarcasism
when they saw one it had been long known
that the flesh that hates was often
described in text revered by Sergeant
Colts who worshiped death Decay and
disease what the hell David Russell
exclaimed picking up the book and
examining it in disbelief you're a
sarkist carpenter asked the fury in his
voice already elevating no I'm not
research David protested I I've never
seen that before it was in your locker
the doctor yelled you're one of those
cannibal cultists this was your plan to
refine the flesh for your Twisted death
worshiping religion it certainly seems
that way button interjected after all
researcher David did seem frustrated at
our earlier results impatient even
you David pointed at the doctor you
planted this in my locker you're here a
sarcast clennan repeated in a nervous
stammer you made me turn the dial to
very fine you made that thing appear you
made me your accomplice anchor tears
streamed on his face clenan's hand
reached for the security officer's gun
and went to draw it planning to shoot
David on the spot but as he went to pull
the weapon from the guard's holster it
wouldn't budge it was then that
assisting clenan stared in horror at his
hand his fingers had fused to the
guard's leg the officer gave a twisted
grin as his torso burst open tendrils of
Flesh latching onto clenin and
assimilating him just like it had done
before the flesh creature broke down its
victim's body making it a new part of
itself a grotesque mass of Limbs and
bloody matter littered with the
discarded faces of those it had infected
the research team looked at it terrified
their stomach's turning disgusted at the
growing growling abomination of bodies
fused to one another oh you're beautiful
Russell heard of voice whisper behind
him he turned to see Barton looking at
the scp-610 creature and smiling
researcher David was the closest and the
creature lunged at him pulling his leg
out from under him screaming in fear the
researcher fell onto the ground and was
dragged towards the flesh it pulled him
in his body stretching his skin tearing
and Bones snapping as he became part of
it a new set of Limbs added to the
monster Dr Carpenter went to try and
pull him free but it was already too
late but he stepped back knowing that if
he touched it he would be infected too
the sound of running caught Russell's
attention and he spotted botton making a
break for it grabbing Dr Carpenter by
the sleeve the researcher pulled him in
the same direction partly running away
from the flesh as it assimilated David
and partly Chasing The sarkic Saboteur
the pair of them quickly caught up to
botton leaning over himself and panting
breathlessly thank God you two made it
he wheezed after the run I can't believe
David could do this to unleash this
nightmare upon us Russell thought to
snap at him to scream how dare he keep
lying but Bottom's back was to him now
he'd never get a better chance there was
a cabinet on the corridor wall
containing a fire ax for emergencies as
carefully and quietly as he could
Russell fished the ax out of its case
while Spartan and carpenter were looking
away we should get the foundation to
lift the lockdown Vaughn was saying they
need to let us out and then oh he let
out a blood curdling scream mid-sentence
as the ax blade wounded him Russell
pulled it back standing over the doctor
as he fell to the floor in agony Russell
have you lost your mind Carpenter
exclaimed no doctor he's the cultist I
have no idea how he tricked Clinton but
that flesh creature exists because of
him the researcher answered from the
floor unable to move thanks to his
injury Dr botton began to laugh it took
me years to infiltrate the foundation so
much time waiting to gain access to that
blessed flesh he gluttoned and now
you've helped me to refine it to create
its ultimate would fall you want to kill
me go ahead Russell my life doesn't
matter for once that creature is free it
will bring about a new age of Flesh and
Grand consist iron will reward me for
the role I played in unleashing it David
was right Carpenter realized button you
you've planted that book on him to throw
us off doctor we need to think of
something researcher Russell interjected
ax still in hand nobody knows more about
the flesh that hates than us there must
be a way to kill that thing otherwise if
it gets out of this lockdown it could
spread to everyone in the foundation
what about fire that's been effective
against 610 infecties before right yes
yes but the doctor desperately tried to
think this new being we've created he
created Russell argued looking at the
grimacing wounded button we cannot deny
the role we've all played in this
researcher Carpenter argued and we have
no idea if it possesses the same
weaknesses as the flesh before its
refinement but we have to try sir the
researcher protested of course I agree
the sickening sound of a slithering
slick Mass was rapidly approaching still
laying on the floor in pain Dr Button
had been dragged to the middle of a
junction with Carpenter and Russell
hiding around either Corner suddenly
botton started hollering as the flesh
came into view practically calling it to
him oh look at you he exclaimed you're
better than I could have ever hoped for
looking down at him with the faces it
had collected the creature stabbed one
of its disgusting appendages through
botton drawing its body into its growing
form I am honored to give my life so
that the age of Flesh May begin the
doctor said weekly through the pain as
he was infected from around the corner
Carpenter had taken the sarkic text and
set its pages on fire with a cigarette
lighter turning to the creature he
hurled the massive burning paper at it
hoping it would be enough fire to spread
to the flesh while it was assimilating
bottom who they had left there as paint
the fiery book collided with the
monstrosity as Russell peeked around the
corner he saw the flesh retreating from
the Flames Bond's body now added to it
for a moment it seemed like the creature
was afraid of the fire but slowly it
drew nearer and nearer to the book with
ease it stamped down the Flames with
button's leg dowsing the fire and
suffering no damage to it at all
gripping the ax in his hands Russell
went to charge of the creature only to
feel something push him back Dr
Carpenter had stopped him run he yelled
instantly Russell turned and raced down
the corridor the sound of fleshy
tentacles whipping through the air he
dared not looked back just in case the
monster was right behind him eventually
he reached another corner and slammed
his back against it hand shuddering as
he held onto the fire ax he had no idea
what had happened to Carpenter maybe it
got him or perhaps he had managed to
give it the slip at the last second
Russell came a hush voice from around
the corner won the researcher recognized
he turned to see Dr Carpenter
approaching him sneaking like he was
trying to avoid being heard I think I
managed to give it the slip doctor
whispered for a second Russell backed up
his hands tightening around the ax
handle this might have looked like Dr
Carpenter but was it are you really you
Doctor yes of course I am Carpenter
replied you don't think that I'm not
that monstrosity Russell raised the ax
defensively only to notice the sadness
in the doctor's face unable to bring
himself to swing even to find out the
researcher lowered his weapon Carpenter
looked grateful come on let's get them
to lift this lockdown he said I'm sure
an MTF can step in and take care of our
mistake as the pair of them cautiously
made their way towards one of the locked
doors Dr Carpenter reached out of hand
to place it on Russell's shoulder now go
and check out scp-610 the flesh that
hates and scp-610 tail aftermath to
experience more unspeakable horrors of
the tainted Flash